residents were still asleep when a fire
ripped through the loafers Lodge in
Wellington just after midnight
the Flames trapped some on the top
floors forcing at least one person to
jump to safety many didn't make it out
for the crews it would have been pretty
horrific Flames coming out of a building
with people inside is our worst
nightmare when you're woken from your
sleep with alarms going smoke people
would have been pretty emotive trying to
escape
fire Crews say the building is unsafe
with the roof at risk of collapse as the
rubble is cleared some people are still
unaccounted for know that two or more
mates have made it out but um
the way things are looking for probably
four other people I know in there and
they I don't know
police say they're still investigating
the cars no safety sprinklers were
installed
what is clear is that the scale of the
tragedy has come as a shock for New
Zealand's Capital this is a major event
we've not seen something on this scale
in recent times and so wellingtonians
will feel this you know Wellington's a
small community many of the occupants
were vulnerable people placed there by
government agencies that's led to
questions about unsafe conditions and
fears it could happen again
Freddy a car Al Jazeera